(slow music)
- [Caine] Saying goodbyes?
- [John] Saying hello.
- [Caine] You think
your wife can hear you?
- No.
- Then why bother?
- Maybe I'm wrong.
- You're going to die.
- Maybe not.
♪ Goodbye to you my trusted friend ♪
- A new day is dawning.
New ideas, new rules, new management.
♪ We've known each other
since we were nine or ten ♪
- Who is this?
- The Marquis de Gramont.
Challenge him to single combat.
Win or lose, it's a way out.
- I don't sit at The Table.
- Your family does.
♪ Please pray for me ♪
♪ I was the black sheep of the family ♪
- A man has to look his best
when it's time to get married...
or buried.
- I'm going to need a gun.
♪ Goodbye my friend, it's hard to die ♪
(gun shots)
(dramatic music continues)
- If you win, The Table
will honor it's word.
(dog growling)
(dog barking)
You will have your freedom.
♪ It's hard to die ♪
- Under the old laws,
only one can survive.
Failure to meet at sunrise
♪ It's hard to die ♪
will result in execution.
- [John] Last words, Winston?
- Just have fun out there.
(Bowery laughing)
(gun shots)
♪ We had joy ♪
♪ We had fun ♪
♪ We had seasons in the sun ♪
- I want you to find your peace.
But a good death only
comes after a good life.
(swords clattering)
- You and I left a good life behind
a long time ago, my friend.
(gun shots)
♪ It's hard to die ♪